professor thierry sherlick is an
orthopedic surgeon in the brussels
university hospital he operates on
hundreds of patients each year carrying
out medical device implants
complications are rare but do happen
yeah the complication a long term
a british study revealed that hundreds
of thousands of patients worldwide may
have been exposed to toxic substances
after undergoing potentially dangerous
hip replacements
to better safeguard patients meps are
extensively revising regulation on this
issue
the main aim is to tighten safety checks
to prevent implants being placed on the
market too quickly the body which allows
the product in the market has to have
better training it has to be
better enforced people have to be really
knowledgeable and the product has to be
looked at it's it can't be like a
shopping tour that whoever wants to have
a product on the market goes where it's
the easiest however for this british mep
increasing controls could result in too
much bureaucracy
if we become too bureaucratic a lot of
medical devices are produced by small
companies smes and this will actually
stop innovation they won't be able to
produce they will just withdraw from the
market so it'll be bad for patients
there will be less innovation less
medical devices out there back at the
operating theater tighter controls are
welcomed but not the detriment of
research
the materials
this new legislation could come into
effect in 2014 and has the potential to
restore patient confidence in opting for
these medical devices